now a special program in living color on
NBC
live the 44th annual Academy Awards
presentation
this is the plaza of the Music Center in
Los Angeles California which tonight is
a suburb of Hollywood since early
morning crowds have gathered to watch
the stars who arrived earlier for
tonight's ceremony like Peter Finch
nominee and Best Actor category for
Sunday Bloody Sunday his lovely aunt
partner and Best Actress nominee for her
own and final college and there's Ben
Jonson Best Supporting Actor nominee for
the last picture show one of the most
beautiful actresses in Hollywood
Jennifer O'Neil
there gene Hackman star of the French
Connection of the nominee there's a
lovely Betty Grable who is thrilled
audiences for years James Caan from The
Godfather
Jane Powell and achaeans Walter Matthau
also a nominee for punch Helen Hayes
first ladies American theater and Jeff
Bridges another nominee as Richard
Jaeckel and Isaac Hayes nominated for
best song from the motion pictures Jeff
the 44th annual academy award show is
brought to you by
Chevrolet building a better way to see
the USA jell-o soft swirl the new
dessert that let you treat your family
like company and the Shell Oil Company
shell products perform
once upon a time many years ago there
was a tiny city wooded and wild and
pretty Holly on with you beautiful and
still as the years went by people came
along
seeing this land they claimed it finding
it wild they tamed it what do you think
they named the great tonight and you
feel good you're a state of mind that
everyone wants to get in a private club
that only a few are ever let in
Hollywood is a trip to pods it's a
wonderland
it's like Santa Claus it's a crazy town
that nobody's ever understood Hollywood
is Marilyn Waring is something right
Hollywood is Gable oh there's famous
night Hollywood is Tracy and efforts
dynamite don't forget
when not a megillah' began the world was
buried with the funny flickering filming
some right fellows started to get it all
together and one day the movies began to
move with lights well action all right
Mabel you're terrified there's no escape
smile Talbot you're enjoying or there's
not much time
haha the trains approaching struggle
Mabel light the fuse Talbot and leave
cray-cray wait someone's approaching
you scream louder now see a Rosco look
at the train look at the fuse to watch
untier take her in your arms rock maple
you're sitting shown really
why waste words when all I want to do is
squeeze you in mine cut one black day
the market went crashing with a bread
lines bankers sleep Larry a backward
glance right away the country was in a
depression so conflicts went into their
song and dance like camera
cut big montage it make is a wing the
mining forties that's a time when
everyone needs a pound so they brighten
everything up with Technicolor Hollywood
was helping the world
happy what was singing again in 1916
musicals were bigger than all the rest
if you want to talk about making lots of
money several pictures reliever that's
the best lights
really sure it's the perfect time to
offer the kid a nice and thanks Jeanette
MacDonald and also Barbara Streisand
the
so from Bali begins by Ally Saudi Press
miss Mae West
here is the president of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences the
Academy award-winning screenwriter mr.
Daniel taradash
music director Henry Mancini every year
of the Academy Awards is an anniversary
this evening in addition we're throwing
a birthday party forgive us if it's a
bit premature actually it will be 6 more
days before Charlie Chaplin is 83
with a steam and affection with many
smiles and not without a few tears we
welcome him home tonight he will receive
our only honorary award but there are
other awards we've been waiting a year
for and we won't have to wait much
longer it's a delight to present our
tour conductor for the early travels of
the evening a two-time Oscar winner as a
lady of the pavements in the sin of
Madeline flow day and the high-flying
stowaway in Airport miss Helen Hayes
as George see Scott didn't get around to
saying last year thank you
for that reception I'm very pleased to
return to California for this very
auspicious occasion and to join with my
friends who will be presenting the
awards tonight gratifying as that roll
is let me tell you that whoever was the
first to say tis better to give than to
receive obviously never was up for an
Oscar let me try to explain to you how
we pick our winners and oh I hope I do
it right because if I don't I'm apt to
get the Academy in trouble we'll be
investigated or something who votes for
the Academy Awards of merit who
nominates them well here's the answer
now first of all all eligible Academy
members are asked to vote for
nominations for the best picture of the
year and then all the other nominations
are done by Academy branches specialists
in their fields actors actors vote for
actors and feel film editors vote for
film editors and then finally all
Academy members are asked to vote by by
sealed ballot for their for the Academy
Award of Merit all of them and those
ballots they send to the special
independent accountants of the Academy
Price Waterhouse and company for
tabulation Price Waterhouse and company
are the only people who know the results
and tonight some representatives of that
firm will be carrying the sealed
envelopes which have inside the names of
the winners and will give them to the
presenters
so I got it out try to remember that
sometime the first Oscar to be presented
to the first winner will be by one of
the nominees of this year and Margaret
and the president of the Screen Actors
Guild John Gavin